I think that climate deniers exploit the
fact that we scientists talk a lot about
uncertainties deniers suggest that
uncertainty means untrue which is a
completely different way of how we
scientists think about uncertainties now
we know that we cannot predict future
climate science relies heavily on
modeling because we obviously cannot
change the climate deliberately and
conduct experiments the climate model is
a mathematical formulation of the
physical processes that play a role for
example fluid motion that is described
by the navier-stokes equations by the
way these equations are the same that
are used to optimize the flight behavior
of airplanes because they demonstrate
the flow around the airfoil we all are
easy to use airplanes that have been
optimized by these equations and by
models we don't think that uncertainty
in that respect equals untrue now once
we have this model we can use that model
in order to conduct experiments like in
a virtual laboratory we can for example
change the assumptions on for example
co2 emissions and see how the climate
system reacts we are able to not only
say how future scenarios change the
climate system but we can even say how
reliable these results are that is why
in the currently released IPCC reports
you can find words like it is likely
very likely or almost certain when we
talk about future climate projections
deniers are skeptics often understand
uncertainty as being not true we
understand uncertainty as being not
completely under our control that means
we have some variability in the data for
example that we need to account for
coming back to your question why do
climate deniers ignore
facts I don't know that I think some do
it because there's always an alternative
opinion in science some do it because
they have massive political or financial
interests in denying the facts some of
them because they simply don't know
better I hope that with these
explanations I could explain the facts a
little bit better and so if you use an
airplane that was optimized by a model
then you can also trust the simulations
and the methods that are behind climate
modeling